um you know if you think about all the
things that you care about they're all
managed by software today your money
your health your government your
elections
your health uh you know like pandemic
response like you name it it's managed
by software and that software is
ridiculously insecure i spent
you know 12 years doing manual code
review manual pen testing side by side
with developers
finding vulnerabilities looking at code
and
you know it's
the number of vulnerabilities is really
staggering
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
today's episode is with the real cyber
security star
meet jeff williams
jeff brings more than 20 years of
security leadership experience as
co-founder and chief technology officer
of contrast
previously jeff was co-founder and ceo
of aspect security a successful and
innovative application security
consulting company acquired by ernest
and young
jeff is also a founder and major
contributor to owasp where he served as
global chairman for eight years and
created the owasp top 10 oasp enterprise
security api o application security
verified standard xss prevention cheat
sheet and many other widely adopted free
and open projects
jeff has a bachelors of arts from the
university of virginia and a masters
from george mason and a jd from
georgetown
you know
there's a lot of cyber security startups
out there
but over the last more than seven years
you've positioned contrast security as a
leading cyber security company
and you know if we're looking at the
pretty much across the software
development life cycle looking at how do
we secure code and and what's happening
with the world today
i'm very much of the belief that no we
haven't really seen
the
the importance of cyber security yet i
think if you're in the industry you
understand it and you see the dangers
and what's happening but to most people
in the world it's still a little bit of
science fiction and still a little bit
out there which
is going to happen one day and so i'm
very thankful for companies like
yourself
which are coming and helping keeping us
secure and and i'd love to start there
jeff yeah you know entrance to cyber
security you've been in this domain for
more than 20 years right what
how do you explain that why cyber
security for you
uh that's a good question i i kind of
got into it by accident uh i
in the 80s i played around with
computers all the time and uh
so i got you know back in those days
they used to copy protect software and
i like cracking those those coffee
protection schemes uh they're like
crossword puzzles to me i don't know
it's just it was fun to like see what
they tried to do to stop you from using
the software a certain way and so i got
into cracking those and then
i don't know just uh stayed with
software and uh my first job was at a
classified navy project
where i learned about real security uh
they were building a b2 level system in
the orange book
very highly secure and i just decided i
was going to learn everything i could
about computer security which back in
those days was almost possible like you
could learn almost the whole field today
it's massive
so it's changed a lot
but still deciding to dedicate your
career to the security side of things
you know you can go building great
applications great consumer products
look at all these different verticals
and you're looking at securing our
software even today what what is you
know what is going through your mind as
you're rationalizing through this
decision to continue in this domain and
in this path
i just think it's such a huge critical
problem um you know if you think about
all the things that you care about
they're all managed by software today
your money your health your government
your elections
your health you know like pandemic
response like you name it it's managed
by software and that software is
ridiculously insecure i spent you know
12 years doing manual code review manual
pen testing side by side with developers
finding vulnerabilities looking at code
and
you know it's
the number of vulnerabilities is really
staggering it's it's funny because
people get outraged when a new
vulnerability comes out and you know
just today there's a new serious
vulnerability in uh in spring uh they're
calling it spring for shell it's going
to be a big deal but
people get all outraged when we find one
vulnerability in a company like you know
equifax or or whatever but
every company has those kinds of
vulnerabilities dozens of them in every
application
so you know we're just it's not that we
couldn't build secure software if we
decided to it's just that we don't and
that irritates me so i've i've kind of
dedicated my life to
trying to fix that in the market
sometimes i feel a little bit like ralph
nader
i love it take me back um
seven eight years the inception of
contrast security
you're an entrepreneur and you're
identifying that there is a gap in the
market for an another leading cyber
security company that is going to
help us secure code across the software
development life cycle
what is your positioning
back then as an entrepreneur and
continuing in the cyber space but now
creating a new company there well we saw
a lot of changes in software around that
time we saw we you know we did a lot of
work with very large enterprises with
thousands of applications sometimes tens
of thousands of applications and
securing application security and
achieving application security at that
scale is really difficult and the tools
that
the legacy kinds of tools in appsec
static analysis dynamic analysis and
wafts were all designed for you know the
early 2000s that's when those products
were invented that's when they came out
and software changed a lot it became
more agile it became more api driven
lots more libraries and frameworks it
moved to the cloud
and devops the speed of software
delivery changed a lot and so we just
looked at it we said hey you know what
we need a new different kind of tool for
a modern kind of software and so we we
created a different way of doing
application security from the inside out
so you know our product works more like
a profiler or a
you know an apm tool like a new relic or
an app dynamics but for security not for
performance
right and so
as you're building this company and as
you're growing it you know there's a lot
of different questions that come into
play one of them that is very very
interesting for me is the go to market
in cyber security space and you're
looking to create a solution that is
going to serve different enterprises
around the world
was that did you have to think of it
very intentionally from the beginning
what was it sort of you know
engineering-led cyber light or more
go-to-market lead for you in the
beginning
well i'd say it's more engineering-led
because
you know
we invented contrast inside my
consulting company
and
then we spun it out as a separate
company
and
but because of where we came from we had
great relationships with lots of large
enterprises and so the go to market was
pretty obvious for us we were going to
sell to the people we know
and
i mean that's actually probably a good
good first step for almost any
entrepreneur but uh
we got a lot of guidance in the first
few years on you know how to make the
product how to get great product market
fit and so on
right okay so contra security if we're
looking today at the cyberspace what i'd
love to is you know go 30 000 feet in
the air
understand sort of the landscape of of
what's happening today in cybersecurity
and then where does contrast fit into
this really complicated maze
yeah
so i like to to
think about the
the cyber security market
according to a framework like if you
think about either the nist framework or
i like actually sunil u's cyber security
matrix but basically you can think about
kind of the
phase of of security from you know like
uh early on it's it's thinking about
detection
and uh requirements and and defenses and
and later on it's about detecting
incidents and response and so companies
kind of array themselves across that
landscape
and then on the vertical dimension
there's you know i kind of think about
the software stack right there's like at
the bottom there's like you know host
and network security then there's
containers and cloud and then at the top
there's application security
there's also people security and mobile
and a few things like that but like
uh
if you think about it that way then
contrast is
out on the application security layer
that's that's what we do and we cover a
pretty broad range across sort of the
the software life cycle and into
production
so that's kind of our goal is to be a
platform to support almost whatever you
want to do in the application security
space
right and and
obviously you do have to go after
specific challenges right even within
that domain so you have to start
somewhere what was sort of the strategy
as you were mapping out the different
offerings that you had for contra
security because you can't start by
saying we're going to offer solution for
the entire life cycle right the first
thing that we built was called contrast
assess and it's this new way of
identifying vulnerabilities from inside
the running application as opposed to
like scanning it from the outside where
you don't have much context doing it
from inside you have all the context you
need so you have access to the code
the data flow the http traffic the
backend connections the libraries the
config
all of that context lets it be much more
accurate
and ultimately
accuracy is the key here to scale
because if you're not accurate you have
to have security experts in the critical
path
and
so by being super accurate we can
empower developers to do it themselves
and that's really when you get devsecops
moving that's the big machinery that you
need in order to scale abstract so
that's where we started and then we
expanded from there
but that's not trivial
getting access to the internals of the
company to understanding how everything
is integrating and to have visibility
into all these different moving pieces
what sort of what are the trade-offs as
you're balancing your ability to
integrate into those areas versus your
you're wanting to be able to to read
everything and to make some decisions on
your own
well just to be clear we started
you know with a technology that would
give us that full access to their
running applications so like it started
right technically and then once we have
great data about
vulnerabilities and exactly where they
are what line of code what you know what
http details and all that then there are
a lot of integrations because a lot of
people need that data
it's not just getting it back to the
developer fast although that really
helps but you know management needs that
data the security teams need that data
operations teams can use that data
there's a lot of places you're right
with a lot of places where we had to
integrate and that's uh you know been an
ongoing process as we build out our
touch points with all the tools that
people are already using
but but getting into
the getting access to the internals of
the company i mean you're coming and
you're saying okay we're a new company
contra security we've built this great
product we're getting visibility we're
going to be able to extract some
insights we're going to become better
and better over the years and by the way
in seven years we'll become sort of a
market leader in this space
but back then
why why did they let you in why are they
opening the door for you this is their
company yeah it's a great question i
mean
some companies won't do business with
small smart startups because they you
know they
they want something that's more stable
but
a lot of companies are willing to uh
you know investigate new approaches they
want to do things that are better new
and faster and better and uh
you know they'll take a flyer on a small
company and we had a really good
reputation coming out of my consulting
company we were established in the space
we you know it's not like we were just
like a couple of guys who'd never done
any abstech before our shin and i had
been doing this for over a decade and
had really strong relationships with
the community we'd we'd released a bunch
of open source
tools in the past uh through oasp so you
know things that were really popular you
know millions and millions of downloads
a year
and you know so we had that that
reputation going into it
the reputation so trust is in
trust is an important factor here right
and i'm guessing it's not just trust in
the company because here you're saying
well actually the fact that we as the
co-founders had this reputation
we are at this point we are the company
the two of us and we have the
credibility yeah that's right that's
what investors invest in a round and
early angel rounds they invest in people
it's not the idea it's it's the people
right okay and and so
you it didn't sound like this was
a significant barrier was there a
turning point when you realized that
okay it's no longer just about
me jeff and my partners but our company
actually has the credibility and has the
you know the stance to be able to go and
and sell into companies that may not
know me jeff
uh
well it
it takes some work i mean you know
that's that's why it takes uh you know
four or five years to get a cyber
security company going is because
you know you have to make some early
sales you have to get great you know
provide great value and measure it and
then be able to get references that will
talk about you and you know you can't
just go from zero to to a hundred
million dollars in air in like a year
you've really gotta you know prove your
value and get your name out there and
you know it just takes some time
right so if we're looking today at cyber
security in in 2022 and like i mentioned
before i think we're just starting i
mean the i think that we're that we're
going to be experiencing some really
interesting things in the next few years
and there's going to be a lot of more
opportunities in the space
where do you think is
sort of the holy grail today in terms of
cyber security what is really the most
pressing thing
that i as a young entrepreneur should be
thinking about when it comes to the
world of securing the cloud or securing
software or hardware yeah i think so i i
have said many times that i think
application security is in the stone age
and i think there's still a lot of great
opportunities in appsec
for the most part companies have been
kind of doing the minimum in apsec uh
you know they off almost every company
has a program but they're not really
you know
they're not really reducing their mean
time to remediate down they're not you
know they're they're not reducing the
number of vulnerabilities they introduce
they're just kind of you know
working it off
what i would say is the big opportunity
is uh i think we're on the cusp of a
transformation in the market where
application security
uh
becomes visible and transparent to
consumers
there's a lot of push from the
government like through the the new
cyber security executive order the
implementing regulations underneath so
there's things like uh you'll have to
produce an s-bomb to tell people what
libraries your application is using
that's a software bill of materials
you're gonna have to publish that about
your software i think you're gonna have
to also um
publish more details about how you build
that software like are you doing
security testing did you train your
developers uh why should i trust your
software
i'd be willing to bet that you bank
online right interesting
right well what do you know about the
software that you're using to manage
your finances
yeah that's crazy right you're you're
blindly trusting that software and we
blindly trust all the software in our
lives that's crazy so the market is
broken
if you can't
but jeff i have a question i mean that's
that but that's why we have brand right
i mean that's why chase and bank of
america you know that's why they're
working so hard at building this brand
of a secure
wall brick wall that's good that that
they're working so hard my question is
you when you're talking about the shift
to consumer transparency and in
individual decision making do you really
think consumers will ever want to read
the software bill of materials and make
and be able to have these independent
thoughts on who's secure and who's not
or is it mainly going to be a marketing
play for who can position themselves on
google as the most secure bank yeah so a
lot of people's initial that's a lot of
people's initial reaction about things
like software labels uh and uh they
think oh well consumers aren't gonna
read those well guess what
nobody read food labels for like 20
years
but they dramatically changed the food
market
because the effect early on in these
labeling regimes is on producers like
the their lawyers won't let them produce
a product that has you know
100 toxic chemicals in it because
they know they'll get sued and the same
thing will happen with software is the
effect will be on the the producers
first to live up to the labels they
won't bring a product to market that has
an f on it just like you don't see
restaurants in new york city that have
uh an f on the window right you well
occasionally you do they get closed down
like you only go to restaurants that
have a's and b's right it's the same
kind of thing here
right
fascinating and so
if we're looking now specifically at
this this idea and i think that's
fascinating this transparency
what what
what shift do companies need to make now
you know if i'm looking at the average
entrepreneur what what kind of thinking
or strategizing should we be doing now
if we're going to if we want to align
ourselves or position ourselves at the
forefront of this new year many
companies are already doing a lot of the
right things many companies are training
developers they're testing their code
they're uh putting automated
security automation into their pipelines
and they are generating
purchasing software like content right
exactly
so i think what they need to do is get
get themselves comfortable with the idea
of disclosing that information uh you
know first internally
and later when they're confident
making it externally uh available i
think i do think it will be a market
advantage for the first companies that
are brave enough to publish this kind of
information uh
i think that it will be really well
received and i think it will create
competition in the market and there'll
be a race to be uh you know the most
secure software producers and the the
companies that do that well will win
their sectors because
being great at software is the key to
unlocking your entire sector it doesn't
matter what you're in it doesn't matter
if you're healthcare finance or
airlines or whatever it's being great at
software is the key
100 100
jeff this was a fascinating conversation
i think i can go on with you for another
hour or two but you have a company that
you need to continue running and so i
really want to thank you for your time
and your energy and the thoughtfulness
and i i appreciate it and
thank you very very much
stay safe and stay healthy and best of
luck with contrast security thanks
michael appreciate it